mr. president mr. Provost Madam
Secretary masters Dean's colleagues
friends families and most of all women
and men of the class of 2012
welcome
welcome to this day this beautiful day
and congratulations I now call on the
senior associate chaplain the Reverend
Ian Oliver well those who wish please
join me in prayer on this day of endings
and beginnings we give thanks to you the
source of life for all that has been and
all that is yet to come we rejoice in
the learning and wisdom attained in this
place the bonds of friendship the love
and support of families the wealth of
memories and the fruits of endeavor and
especially the promise and challenge
that lie ahead bless all who gather here
this day and bless these graduates to be
a blessing to the world may your light
illumine and your truth guide their way
now and always amen
a selection from psalm 43 send forth
your light and your truth they will lead
me they will bring me to your holy
mountain to your dwelling place that I
may come to the altar of God God my
delight my joy that I may praise you
with the liar oh god my god Matthew
chapter 5 verses 14 through 16 you are
the light of the world a city built on a
hill cannot be hid no one after lighting
a lamp puts it under the bushel basket
but on the lamp stand and it gives light
to all in the house in the same way let
your light shine before others so that
they may see your good works and give
glory to your father in heaven Salaam
alaikum God is the light of the heavens
and earth the likeness of his light is
that of a niche in which there is a lamp
the lamp is in a glass the glass is as
it were a brilliant star lit from a
blessed tree and olive neither of the
East nor of the west whose oil seems to
glow even though no fire has touched it
light upon light god guides whom He
wills to his light God makes parables
for humanity and God has knowledge of
everything
you
you
you
well this seems awfully quick weren't we
just meeting here a few short months
years ago for your freshman assembly how
did that happen on this occasion
baccalaureate it's customary for the
president to deliver a baccalaureate
address and for the Dean of Yale College
to offer a few readings so make
yourselves comfortable for some words
I've chosen to share with you in your
daily travels at Yale you have walked
through this building where we are today
Woolsey Hall on a regular basis some of
you have walked through the Rotunda
dozens of times a week you think of this
space as Commons or as the grand concert
hall that surrounds us but what is this
building it is a war memorial and this
is once again this commencement weekend
just a week before Memorial Day weekend
when we think of and we honor those who
have died in their nation's service from
Lexington Massachusetts to Afghanistan
but the commemoration and the formation
of a holiday that would take place in
May took shape after the Civil War when
more Americans died than in all the
other wars in which US soldiers have
fought the names of Yale soldiers Union
and Confederate north and south are
inscribed just outside this hall 150
years ago in 1862 this nation was in the
midst of this terrible war friends and
classmates had taken up arms against one
another by the end of the war and after
700,000 yes nearly three quarters of a
million had died President Lincoln
closed his second inaugural in this way
with malice toward none with charity for
all with firmness in the right as God
gives us to see the right let us strive
on to finish the work we are in to bind
up the nation's wounds to care for him
who shall have borne the battle and for
his widow and his orphan to do all which
may achieve and cherish a just and
lasting peace among ourselves and with
all nations a just and lasting peace
Yale students by and large young men
from New England in 1865 would have read
those words in a local newspaper perhaps
reading the text aloud to one another
those students knew the rent in the
National fabric the broken bones of the
united states that had not yet begun to
knit together we continue to strive for
healing now nearly 150 years later in
both national and international respects
lincoln calls for this in his formal
speech to his countrymen to remember to
care for him his widow his orphan as
part of its continuing series about the
sesquicentennial of the Civil War the
New York Times ran us the story about
the short life of a foot soldier killed
at Gettysburg in 1863 and whose orphaned
children became symbols of the wars
sacrifice The Times has given the fallen
soldier a new life in a story of
hardscrabble farming wailing and battle
compellingly revealed in his letters to
his wife where one learns that they were
one another's best friends in the short
lines of his last letter home he found a
way to express the depth of his love for
his friend if I ever live to get home
you will not comply
being lonesome again or of sleeping cold
for I will lay as close to you as the
bark to a tree Amos Humiston days before
the Battle of Gettysburg you arrived
here as strangers remember those few
short years ago when provo salivate then
Dean Sal of a welcomed you here as did
President Levin as you make your plans
to leave you leave as friends many of
you have been my own friends it's been
my great joy to know so many of you and
in my days as a college master you class
of 2012 were my last class here's what
happens to you Yale undergraduates along
the path of the four years you change
you acquire new knowledge much of it
useful some of it quirky you learn how
to ask better questions a generation or
two learn to do this through a
children's encyclopedia known as The
Book of Knowledge perhaps the addition
of 1936 from which this prose poem by a
Yale faculty member is conceived whose
black and cracked spines sat on a shelf
in my family home the reading for long
winters stay with me for 17 questions as
I take you to from the book of knowledge
by Cynthia Zarin 2010 1 what makes a
fairy ring fairy rings are made of a
kind of fungus too why does stamp air
make us ill damp air is often cold air
and the cold has usually been blamed for
making us ill although many facts prove
that it is not blameworthy at all three
why does a dog go round and round before
it lies down the answer to this question
lies in another question what is a dog
for
can our brains ever fill up the poet
browning says there is no end to
learning 5 why does a tuning fork sound
louder when it touches would the sound
from a tuning fork like the light from a
candle flows out in all directions 6 why
are some things poisonous we could only
answer this question completely and
fully if we knew all there is to know
about life
7y can we hear better when we shut our
eyes this question is partly true and
partly not true 8 can an animal think
there is no doubt an animal can think
and that it can remember 9 do animals
feel pain as we do that is not a
question that can be answered directly
10 why do we not growl like animals when
we are hungry a hungry man is an angry
man 11 why have leaves different shapes
the great idea which we learn to apply
to every fact about living creatures is
that these facts usually have uses 12
why did the leaves of the aspen always
shake the shaking of the leaves has the
same effect as if the trees were Fanning
themselves 13 why does oil make a wheel
go round more easily it all depends on
where the oil is put
14 why do we see the stars only at night
the stars are shining all the time
sending light to earth but more than
this is needed for us to see 15 is an
atom alive it is almost a living thing
16 can country people see writ small
better than townspeople if country folk
used their eyes mainly at distances
their vision will be keenest at
distances 17 why does a lump rise in my
throat when I cry it is the place of
speech which is the most marvelous thing
finally it is a yale college tradition
to read a passage by John Milton on this
occasion I think you know this story
there were these two young 20-somethings
well maybe they were even just teenagers
and they were in a garden it was a
perfect place and they knew that and
they also couldn't stop themselves in
wanting to know about the world beyond
they couldn't help but want to know
about it I think as in that zarin poem
there was a thirst for knowledge and
then there was a wardrobe malfunction
remember that part like you and as you
may particularly feel on Monday
afternoon or tuesday morning their
departure seemed to them sudden
unwarranted abrupt but inevitable from
Paradise Lost by John Milton 1667 some
natural tears they dropped but wiped
them soon the world was all before them
where to choose their place of rest and
Providence their guide
they hand in hand with wandering steps
and slow through Eden took their
solitary way congratulations class of
2012 good afternoon before I begin my
remarks I want to welcome especially the
parents of our graduates I know how very
special this weekend is for you my wife
and I have shared this experience four
times at the commencement of each of our
children and I know that you are
bursting with pride so let's celebrate
together and let me ask the proud
families and friends of our graduates to
join those of us on stage by rising and
offering warm congratulations to the
class of 2012
and now I would like to ask the class of
2012 in turn to reflect for one moment
on how you came to reach this milestone
now that you've done that one of the
things that must have occurred to you
during that moment of reflection is that
there are many people here today your
parents siblings relatives and friends
whose support and encouragement made
your achievements here possible so why
don't you rise now and show them your
appreciation
members of the class of 2012 I imagine
you're finding it difficult to believe
that your time here has come to an end
let me tell you from experience your
memories of Yale College and the lessons
you have learned here will endure but
you have so many exciting possibilities
ahead of you that the sense of loss you
feel today will fade quickly and think
of all that you've accomplished you have
opened for yourselves worlds that you
never knew existed when you came here
four years ago you have discovered that
you love philosophy or music or our
history or archaeological fieldwork or
analyzing economic data or computer
images of the stars or characterizing
endophytes that you've garrett or that
you gathered on a trip to a rainforest
or helping to build a quantum computer
nearly 900 of you spent at least one
summer or semester in South America or
Africa or Asia or Europe learning a
language doing research working as an
intern or taking a course led by a Yale
professor you have learned the value of
seeing the world and the value of
appreciating differences among people
you have worked hard you've had fun
you've made friends for a lifetime and
you've come to know yourselves better
than before not only from the books that
you've read and the courses you've taken
not only from the overseas experiences
that you've had but also from your
endless discussions with classmates
about your beliefs hopes and aspirations
you've also learned something here about
responsibility you've lived in
communities communities formed by your
sweet
it's your entryway your college as well
as in communities defined as singing
groups Chamber Orchestra's dramatic
societies service organizations
publications religious organizations
athletic teams fraternities sororities
or societies living in these communities
and making them work has been a big part
of your experience you have learned that
as gifted and as talented as you are and
you are it is not all about you it's all
about us you have learned that making
communities productive and a positive
experience for all means taking account
of the perceptions feelings and
aspirations of others living in some of
Gail's many communities has made you a
better listener more respectful of
others and better equipped to serve and
lead in the world beyond these walls and
what of that world that you are entering
there are big communities out there in
which you will have roles and therefore
responsibilities we are a global
university and each of you has a nation
to which you now have an opportunity to
contribute problems abound all around
the world and the choices of different
choices of direction are confronting
every nation Europe is debating
austerity versus growth in the aftermath
of Arab Spring Middle Eastern and North
African countries are testing whether
democracy can thrive China is struggling
to find a way to distribute the fruits
of increased prosperity more equitably
and to diminish the adverse
environmental impact of rapid growth the
argument I want to advance now applies
equally to those of you with
responsibilities as citizens of
countries around the world but I will
focus for the
moment on the United States where all of
you have chosen to attend school surely
you've noticed that there is a
presidential election going on but it
does not seem to have captured the
imagination of many of you as elections
have often in the past I think I know
why I think it's because the issues that
truly matter for the nation and the
world are not at center stage and there
are for sure issues that truly matter
how do we create a sustainable
foundation for long-run prosperity with
good jobs created and ever-increasing
numbers to spread the fruits of growth
more equitably across the population how
do we provide high-quality and humane
health care at a cost we can afford how
do we prevent the continued consumption
of fossil fuels from warming our planet
to the point that ecosystems are
destroyed food supplies are threatened
and rising sea levels force hundreds of
millions to relocate and as a nation how
do we engage with a world in which the
distribution of power and influence is
inevitably becoming more multipolar it's
not that these issues are being
altogether ignored for example competing
approaches to revitalizing the economy
are very much the subject of debate but
the issues are typically broken into
unconnected pieces and discussed in
terms that reflect overly oversimplified
ideological preferences rather than
serious analysis we talk about whether
to increase the debt ceiling as if this
were a religious issue or whether to
extend the tax cuts enacted a decade ago
as if this in itself were the single
question defining the proper role of
government in the economy meanwhile we
ignore serious deliberation of how to
undertake and finance on a substantial
scale
l the investments in infrastructure
innovation and education that are of
fundamental importance to our future
well-being the issue of climate change
seems to have disappeared under the
table buried in an avalanche of
know-nothing advocacy that disparages
decades of disinterested scientific
research and the implications of a shift
in the distribution of power among
nations are simply not in the debate
chamber instead we talk about securing a
new American Century as if continued
global dominance were a national
objective I do believe that America can
prosper and lead in the 21st century but
the global landscape today is far
different than it was in 1945 on the
Cold War when the World War two ended or
1989 when the Cold War ended we should
be talking now about how we might work
effectively with other nations in the
context of more widely shared power and
responsibilities I was pointedly
reminded of the poverty of our current
political discourse when a couple of
weeks ago professor steven smith who
recently stepped down as master of
branford college you can fear
he's up in the balcony gave me a college
a giving gave me a copy of his new
edition of the writings of Abraham
Lincoln just published by the yale
university press press how utterly
refreshing it is to read lincoln's
beautifully written closely argued
speeches and letters that grapple
directly deeply and forcefully with the
issues of his time of course lincoln's
main preoccupation was with the subject
of slavery and he addresses that issue
with a rigor and depth of argument that
is simply unknown in American political
discourse today but he also touched
brilliantly on other subjects of more
direct relevance to our current
situation in a speech given in Milwaukee
to the Wisconsin State agricultural
Association in September of 1859 Lincoln
addressed the full range of issues
associated with deriving maximal social
benefit from the development of what was
then the nation's most significant
natural resource its fertile and
abundant agricultural land like so many
of Lincoln's speeches this one is
remarkable for displaying an
extraordinary mastery of his subject
matter his discussion focused on the
need for continued innovation as a means
to greater productivity and prosperity
to enable such innovation he stressed
the importance of infrastructure in the
form of access to adequate supplies of
water and he especially emphasized the
need for education farmers said Lincoln
need not only to be literate but also to
have a working knowledge of botany
chemistry and the mechanical arts one
might have thought that Lincoln's vision
of increasing prosperity through
investments in innovation infrastructure
and education might have been set aside
in the face of the overwhelming priority
of Civil War that confronted him six
weeks after taking office but no within
a period of two years working with
Congress Lincoln was able to enact
legislation
authorizing a Transcontinental Railroad
the Homestead Act enabling the
establishment of farms across the tear
the western territories and the moral
act granting land for the establishment
of colleges to teach agriculture and the
mechanical arts colleges that
subsequently became our treasured state
universities these public investments
were the foundation of late 19th century
America's prosperity we need to make
such investments again today we need to
repair our crumbling infrastructure our
highways ports railroads and airports as
well as waste and water management
traffic control and communication
systems to make possible the flow of
innovations upon which our economy
depends we need to maintain our
commitment to investing in science and
to equip our citizens with the skills
required to become productive and
competitive in a modern technology
enabled workplace we need to make large
and well-directed investments in both
basic K through 12 education and in
specialized technical training the gap
in earnings between the highly educated
and the poorly educated has grown
dramatically in the last three decades
and the earnings of those without a
college education have not even kept up
with inflation educating our workforce
is the most effective way to prevent
rising income disparity on Monday
morning I will confer upon you the
degrees in Yale College recommended by
your Dean and I will at that moment
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities not rights and
privileges which is the language used at
most of our peer institutions you
already have had the privilege of the
finest education on the planet now you
will assume the responsibilities that
are entailed by your privilege
by using the powers of reason and
expression that you have developed here
by drawing upon your wide exposure to
many disciplines and forms of discourse
each one of you has the capacity to make
a difference in the quest for a better
world for yourselves and for future
generations you can start by engaging in
the public debate about the investments
needed to secure our future and the
perspective needed to operate
effectively in a multipolar world you
can bring rigor and seriousness to the
political dialogue and insist that
others do so as well by rejecting
superficial ideological slogans that are
no substitute for true argument and you
can engage more directly in repairing
the world through the career paths you
choose and the organization's you join
and support I'm not saying that you all
need to take up public service or teach
school although I hope and I trust that
some of you will instead I'm urging you
to engage with the future by helping to
raise the sights of your communities as
Yale graduates traditionally have and
not to confine your activity merely to
the private pursuit of health wealth and
happiness this is where I started by
reminding you that Yale is not merely a
place that enabled you to define and
transform yourselves as individuals it
has been for each of you a network of
many communities in which you were
expected to participate and in which you
were expected to contribute the world
outside is no different we need you to
engage to consider the well-being of
others as well as yourselves we need you
to take responsibility Lincoln closed
his Wisconsin speech with a memorable
passage inspiring his audience with his
inimitable
and graceful pros not to accept the
world passively but to work actively
toward its betterment he said and I
quote let us hope that by the best
cultivation of the physical world
beneath and around us and the
intellectual and moral world within us
we shall secure an individual social and
political prosperity and happiness whose
course shall be onward and upward and
which while the earth indoors shall not
pass away women and men of the class of
2012
congratulations your accomplishments
inside and outside the classroom have
earned our heartfelt praise and
admiration you've expanded your own
horizons and you've sustained and
improved the life of yale's many
communities now is the time to build
flourishing lives for yourselves and
also to strive for the betterment of
your communities local professional
national and global help these
communities cultivate the world around
us and the world within us take
inspiration from Lincoln and from your
own experience here at Yale and make
your course and the course of those
without the privileges accorded to you
onward and upward congratulations
you
Oh
you
you
may God bless and keep you may the
eternal one show you favor and be
gracious to you may the Holy One cause
light to shine upon you and grant you
peace amen
you